hello and welcome to this video please
meta 08 here with black see if I can get
I can apply and let's do this the coop
right cheek variation it's a bit of a
sideline okay he went with g3 this is
always playable g3 setups I'm going to
play the ravening and style here maybe I
should have taken yeah I know is going
going back with the night still it
shouldn't be it shouldn't be a big deal
I think I should have taken but we'll
see this is possible now g5 I can take
and retreat the night kiss me to be five
square not sure if he wants to play g5
em here it goes for it so the thing is
if I would if I would have the possible
to go to the seven this would actually
be quite good but I don't don't have the
possibility
okay over 25 so it's giving up the
square but it's just one square many
others on the water
yeah so what to do here this beef be
five I don't know if it actually helps
let's do this didn't expect him to thick
head already what happens he's not
putting much pressure on this night
surprisingly I wonder if f6 as a move
just for me to open it up he's got
bishop age three though
interesting ok King g7 is strange and
this is I can never play probably even
though there are still owe some pieces
on the dangle I was trying to save mmm
how do I f6 s bishop age three year
against is a problem otherwise I would
actually like this idea his King is also
not very safe I don't quite know how to
set up this so like this idea though but
Alicia page three I don't see a reply f5
very strange
yes actually hangs b7 man taking far too
long just quite interesting this
position yeah i'm hanging be seven but i
wasn't sure that this is actually a
problem Queen h5 there is create but
maybe then we will take b7 our queen h5
is not clear that it threatens much even
push it be a this may be possible f5 was
a strange booth levels probably crazy
idea I don't know i sat on this for a
long time and I couldn't really find
something that I liked that's very slow
and maybe just weekly one or something
by taking edge for him check when this
c8 Hanks a complete mess really a total
mess what's going on Bishop g5 pretty
much have to take that
that looks vieta anyway the transmission
are for winning the Queen maybe hook
five or something I mean those those
moves could work my honor whoa it's a
fluke so I have to maybe gamble on that
it's tricky to figure out in one minute
anyway now I'm probably the fact that
looks like it should should work out
before pong pong take screen takes maybe
night of six works time morning my dears
with age six next
yeah here we go but is it really winning
Queen takes Knight f6 I don't see it
currently I wish we should take snow but
that that should work Queen takes Knight
f6 cap 97 I've covered
brooke cheaper probably 26
check check okay white point I found out
it was probably lost somehow yeah I
really couldn't find a good solution
here yeah like one move move later this
are no f6 yeah I felt f6 is correct but
he a ever and this doesn't really I can
cover the same thing as if he takes I
mean his position is very loose yeah
with with this year I've got the save
King down this looks pretty awful but I
didn't didn't quite didn't quite get it
yeah it still have six you know I looked
at this too late because Quincy aid
wasn't available anymore still f's exam
this was this irritated me at the end
you'll just wants to take I thought this
would work I have to check calm and then
Queen to e3 and so yeah this is what I
have to do that would would kill why but
I didn't see it and instead when the f5
and here I'm probably in trouble let's
see tune looks very logical yeah f5 was
a crazy idea 95 this is cute
wow this is so funny Lauren check okay
thank you Oh check Oh be still in
trouble here never hear things hear
things are looking up who she ate yeah
it's funny himself a self fork but I
wanted to go to the G file so at least
it seems I was right that the sacrifices
didn't didn't really work ha yeah Queen
takes the one out of six or Bishop
Knight of 60 97 actually so I have to do
this so it wouldn't have worked but
didn't blunder stuff here but it doesn't
seem to be a mid-cap reasonably yeah
well coordinated yes I went ahead ahead
f6 here that was a lot not stronger ok
guys thanks for watching